[Music]
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
oh nothing like the kitty giving us some
delicious Amy Winehouse to get this
party started what's up guys welcome
back to unmasking the masked singer
still in quarantine I'm Deidre Behar
joined by and I'm Charlie O'Keeffe and
we are here to talk about the Kitty's
big elimination tonight Deidre were you
shocked yes I was shocked I really
thought she was a front-runner and you
know what I think we're gonna celebrate
her all night tonight
there you know we got the cheetah the
carriers were ready it will let's jump
right into it the Kitty's sing back to
black but sadly after tonight's
elimination she's heading back to the
litter box Taylor
I'm glad that this experience has given
me the chance to kind of break out of
that so thank you Oh Charlie I am proud
of us I have to totally gloat for a
second we figured out that it was Jackie
Evancho the little girl with the big
voice who's not such a little girl
anymore I think this show was so
transformative for her in so many ways
because we met her as a young girl and
we were you know he's so impressed by
these these vocal chops that she has but
she really proved on this show that I'm
20 years old now please stop thinking of
me as a child I'm a woman and I think
through the song choices that she made
on this show it's probably gonna be an
indicator of where her career goes next
like a little sexier a little more
grown-up a little more sophisticated and
like we saw with Hunter Hayes last week
it's a rebirth and I think we're gonna
do that here again with the kitty aka
Jackie Evancho what did you think I mean
I remember watching her on a GT when she
was 10 years old now she's 20 literally
ten years later we're seeing her on
another competition show and it's a
completely different Jackie and like you
said it's kind of a rebirth story and
I'm excited to see where she goes from
here especially after some of the vocals
we heard throughout the past few weeks I
mean girls got girls got some vocal
cords and she could definitely sing some
pop songs as well yeah I mean I go back
to that first performance of dangerous
woman I mean we got leg we got arm
we got all the sassy like burlesque
elements in there so I salute her she's
20 she's a fierce woman no pun intended
go out and do you Queen Jackie Evancho I
cannot wait to see what she does exactly
and sadly with Jackie gone we do have
something great to look forward to we
officially have our top four for season
three we will be seeing this top four it
this week next week and eventually in
two weeks we'll be down to the top three
for the season three finale but we are
gonna jump right into it and first up we
have the Frog who is busting his moves
week after week take a look
[Music]
[Applause]
all right another week the frog were
sticking with our og guess Wow Wow of
course I'm gonna be completely honest
because I feel like my expectations are
so high because he delivers so much
every single week this actually wasn't
my favorite frog performance I really
loved what he did last week where he
performed more of a rock song that was
super left-field for him um tonight just
kind of felt like you know that's what
Paolo does he raps and he gives us big
performances so he gets an a-plus-plus
for energy and big performance I mean
what did you think definitely still a
front-runner in my mind and I think the
judges eyes as well and speaking of the
judges I was very happy to see you mr.
Robin Thicke guess Bow Wow for now two
weeks in a row so he's onto something
yeah well let's get right into the clue
package what did you notice so we saw a
lot of references to a tadpole it was
kind of on like the GPS in the car it
was like a little tadpole reference this
could be something referencing bauhaus
nine year old daughter who he actually
spoke about after the performance saying
he wanted to win for his kid yeah you
know they're super close if you follow
him on Instagram and they just have like
a really special frog tadpole bond well
um really cool this week they did a
borrowed package clue so everybody who's
at home and Quarantine like one of the
small joys of life is we're still
getting our online packages right so the
masked singer showed these deliveries
that have been showing up at the
characters houses and the frogs delivery
was a model airplane now let me tell you
why this makes sense for Bow Wow a
couple years ago Bow Wow was involved in
something called the bow-wow challenge
after he posted a photo of a private jet
and then someone saw him on an airplane
and uploaded the photo saying he's not
on a private jet he's on a commercial
flight with me right here so it turned
into this whole like a viral trend where
you post a photo that looks like
something very luxurious or glamorous
and then you post the reveal of how your
life is actually really boring and
mundane so I feel like it even I believe
robbed and brought this up
the plane is referring to the bow-wow
challenge do you agree I agree I think
it's a very kind of hidden clue but also
when you Dakota and look back at his
viral moments it makes a lot of sense
and I loved it bow-wow owned it like he
totally thought it was funny he hopped
on the trend like it's not like
something embarrassing he totally owned
it and I think the fact that he did that
in the past and then showed it as a clue
tonight I'm agreeing with you and I'm
happy to see that Robin is jumping on
board with not well well moving on one
thing is certain we have not lost that
loving feeling for the Rhino take a look
Oh another great performance from the
Rhino who we think is Barry Zito he
former MLB player turned country star to
the affectionately called merry
tortellini let's get right into his Glu
package you know this is a recurring
theme with the Rhino and we saw it a lot
tonight a lot of talk about his wife and
what an instrumental key player she's
been in kind of getting him into this
really incredible place in life whether
it's his health his mental health his
career he really credits his wife mrs.
Rhino with being the driving force and
we know that he's talked about it in
documentaries he was reading all these
self-help books said he didn't know what
to do and when he met his wife
amber former Miss Missouri she said you
got to cut all the books down there's
one book with all the answers and it's
the Bible and they're a very religious
couple they're they're people of faith
and I think if it doesn't surprise me
that mrs. RINO has been such an integral
part of every single clue package
speaking of which we also saw in the
clue package a photo of three baby
elephants well Barry and his wife Amber
have three children they just welcomed
their third actually in February so it
kind of coincides with the whole
production of the masked singer which is
excited what do you think I mean listen
you just broke down to everything there
was a lot there and yeah so a round of
applause to you for that jumping to his
borrow to clue from the package they
stole from outside his house we saw a
Navy hot well I think we've mentioned it
in weeks past that there's actually a
few ties to Barry Zito and the Navy the
first he's worn many hats as we heard
him say he's played for many teams in
the MLB also in 2003 he actually
appeared on jag in an episode and played
a u.s. Navy officer which is a really
cool tie but there is a lot more to add
to the list I think we mentioned it too
weeks ago but him and his wife are
actually huge US military supporters and
they found it a charity called strikeout
for troops so that is awesome he's been
involved with the military for a long
time and I thought it was a cool clue
because there are so many different nods
to his life in it so many and I love
that he's a triple threat actor
Skinner sports star he does it all
well I think we can all agree with the
judges that this will not be the night
angels
last stance take a look
[Applause]
deidre I am overwhelmed this week listen
we got Donna Summer we got the night
angel we got candy bars who I think is
the night angel singing Donna Summer I
mean I I watched this performance four
times I just kept rewinding re-watching
there is so much here and I'm living for
all of it
we're absolutely born in the wrong era
jumping right into the clue packages we
saw fan mail we saw some different
stocks of letters all addressed to the
night angel well guys fan mail is the
name of the 1999 TLC album which candy
helped co-write no scrubs which is on
that album and a little fun fact I
didn't know no scrubs was actually
originally gonna go to her girl group
xscape and it ended up with TLC so candy
has a lot of ties here to the album
fanmail
well I'm glad you broke that down
because when I was watching that I
thought that was just a blatant screw
the clue I thought they were trying to
mess with us and make us think that it's
you know chili or t-boz but I totally
agree with you on that one um I want to
move on to her bar aid package clue so
we got to see some winter wonderland
stuff going on we saw purple snow boots
and some ski goggles so I think the
whole like Ken pointed this out the
whole chill of it all meaning is it
chilly I think that again was a red
herring I think it's actually a tip to
kandi Burruss spin-off show on Bravo
called candy is a ski trip it was a
documentary series of course that
followed her life and with her husband
Todd Tucker as a blended family and they
go on a ski trip together
so kandi loves the winter huh have you
lived on a summer and the winter sign me
up for all of it well moving on lastly
we have our favorite serenading shel
wearing turtle take a listen
[Music]
I'm sorry was that a religious
experience for you because it was for me
yes oh my gosh Jesse McCartney who we've
been saying from the get-go is the
turtle performing a Coldplay cover for
the ages oh so good let's get right into
the clue package we saw a yellow and
again this is not that deep guys if you
look back at Jesse's og boy band days
when he was in dream Street the way that
like the media and I think bands
described his haircut was mop top and I
think the fact that it was a yellow mop
is a nod to him being a blond hungry
totally if you thought the Justin Bieber
swoop was a thing Jesse McCartney did it
first with the motto go back 10 years
absolutely the other thing I want to
point out because it's been a recurring
clue that we see pop up a lot we got
tortilla chips last week this week we
got poker chips and they have to be a
reference to Alvin and the Chipmunks
red-green-blue Alvin Simon Theodore and
of course Jesse is the voice-over artist
for the role of Theodore and all the CGI
action belts listen one can hope that
next week there's a monk clue and then
it'll really just chipmunk tie it all
together producer hat is on package this
was definitely the creepiest of the
night and the largest borrowed package
we saw on stage it was a zombie a
full-sized dead man zombie on stage it
was charity
well Jesse actually played read on fear
The Walking Dead which was supposed to
be a prequel to AMC's super popular show
Walking Dead so jesse has a tied to
zombies and a weird vibe what the guy
does it all boy band does it singing
does it pretend to be a zombie on
television he does it he's nice man and
honestly after tonight he's my pick to
win and I do want to point out Nicola
actually did Gus Jesse McCartney this
weekend even referenced that clue way
back when we saw in one of the first
weeks of her performing with him on The
Today Show
way back early 2000 so
nicole has her gears grinding and she's
pinpointing Jessie to the turtle yeah we
agree Nicole it's Jessie for sure
well Deidre like I said earlier we
officially have our top four season
three mask singer finalists moving
forward next week one more will go home
and then we will have the three compete
in the grand finale in two weeks but
left remaining in the competition we
have the turtle the Rhino the night
angel and the Frog and something very
interesting here the judges have
actually guessed all the people who we
think are also under those masks however
they never guessed Jackie that is
correct and guess what exciting news
everybody Charlie and I will be speaking
with Miss Jackie Evancho herself we're
gonna get to the bottom of everything
she did on this show at the top of my
list I want to know why those eyes were
different colors yes those were
definitely trying us off people need to
know yes so if you have questions tweet
us let us know and of course we'll see
you back here next week we are getting
down to the nitty-gritty people we are
so close to crowning a winner on season
three of the masked singer so stay safe
enjoy yourself and we'll see you next
week hi guys
[Music]